-[objects clatter]
-[aswang 2] Hey!
The only way you can get in--
[groans, thuds]
Greetings, Ibwa, Chief of the Sapa Clan.
I am Alexandra Trese.
[footsteps]
Good evening, Captain Guerrero.
Hello, Alexandra. Thanks for coming down.
I had a feeling
you might want to see this.
I admit, I was curious
when you described the circumstances.
So, is it…
[Alexandra]
The White Lady of Balete Drive.
Any witnesses, Lt. Tapia?
[Tapia] No, ma'am.
But one of the neighbors positively
ID'd the victim as "Gina Santos."
[Tapia] We checked it, and it turns out
she committed suicide in…
-[paper rustles]
-"…1995."
Wait, that can't be right.
Ancient runes crudely done.
-[Alexandra] Clearly ritual sacrifice.
-[scrapes]
The bigger question is,
who would want to kill a ghost and why?
Cover me.
[gunshots]
[growling]
[slashes]
-[grunting]
-[flesh pierces]
[yelling]
[both grunting]
[grunts]
-[slashes]
-[groans]
[flesh rips]
[hair rustles]
[tense music]
[cloth rustles]
[tense music continues]
-[line dialing]
-[fire roars]
[growls]
Good evening, little Trese.
What game shall we play today?
Greetings, Great Santelmo.
I'm afraid this is business,
and I need your help
to uncover what happened.
Well, you're no fun.
The souls who were killed
in this car are here,
yet, they are not, and they are not alone.
I sense spirits on fire.
[Santelmo] People who had burned
to death in their sleep.
They, too, are making the journey.
How can the souls be here
and yet not be here?
We are standing in two trains right now.
[Santelmo] One for the living…
And the other for the dead.
Thank you, Santelmo.
May the great light shone upon you.
[fire roars]